Please join me in welcoming along
with her daughter Peta Ani to Franco
[inaudible].
Oh, hello. Thanks.
Okay,
the mothership. Really cool.
Oh, what's happening to me?
Technical difficulties.
Oh,
let's just leave it like that.
Okay. You want to sing a tune?
This is not from my latest record.
This is just a song that Pete
and I like to sing together.
You facing east or west or north to south.
When it gets cold out,
do you get brought in that you get left?
You in the shade.
If something big but
you ride out in the sun,
are you down then at
the top 10 either way,
you better take your,
make your lemon may have you raised.
Yeah.
Have you felt the longing in a sea
if you felt it swimming in?
It's sneaky
pushing through
and you know what I'm saying
when I'm saying it's going to be,
oh,
you just got to take your,
make your,
have your radio.
Listen to beating of the drum.
Look at the spouse.
Yeah.
Who says it's better to be dry?
The mighty oak trees are
so happy they could cry.
So you just gotta take your,
make your nay have your rainy,
have your rainy day.
Have you been rainy?
Rainy,
okay.
Never play guitar twice.
They get dirty.
So that was fine. I was thinking
when we were singing that song,
if that second verse, have you felt
a longing in a seed, that's you.
You're the seed that I was writing about
and now you're here singing with me and
this is a song that I
wrote for Peter's dad
long after the seal is broken.
You stumble.
I senior choke and I think
I love you even more.
[inaudible] they got the field.
Can you hold on to your passion now?
The wheat, Beau's got tired. Ebs Is,
I think I love you even.
Wow.
Come here. Bring me back to when
we were slip, then sues. Cry, sad.
Think I love
even,
even, even, even,
even even blow
sales.
Sneak backwards.
So around the baby to the placenta.
I think I love you even
retroactive DNA. What's
attractive? Who could say,
I say God stuff. Yeah, even
stars.
Then they few blue blues singer even.
Huh?
Come here.
Bring it back to when we would slip
through the cracks then got up.
Yeah.
Even, even, even, even,
even, even, even,
even mark,
oh
hmm.
Long after the seal is broken,
seen me.
[inaudible] you see me choke and
he think he could love even more
when sat on your role,
Scott,
I think it could love me even
you passion now we both got tire das is,
could you love me even
come here.
Bring me back to when we were slipping
through the cracks then God love Ya.
Even mark or even, even, even, even,
even, even, even,
even,
even though even blow.
Alrighty.
Thank you.
Talk for a minute
please. Another round of applause.
Ani to Franco at to Franco.
[inaudible].
I want to thank you so much.
Thank you for the beautiful performance
and thank you for taking the time to
come and visit with us here in New York.
I know you have a lifelong
history in here in New York,
but having relocated, you've been
spending a lot of time back up here. Uh,
you were up here a few months ago to
receive a lifetime achievement award.
Is that correct?
Right, yes. One of those.
That's always good.
Now I can die
of a lifetime is what I'm understanding.
Yeah, no, that's cool. I love coming
back to New York. I do. I do. I, um,
I used to miss it like a
person after I left. Um,
and now I just like to visit,
like we were talking about,
we were talking all morning off Mike, so
now we get to talk into Mike's. But yeah,
now the whole pace of New
York and the, just the circus
of it, I'm like, wow, cool.
Got to go.
Well,
and you're here now for kind of a wild
event supporting Cindy Lopper and the
true colors foundation.
Yeah.
The benefit to help an organization that
tries to get a homeless queer youth,
a place to be and people to support them.
Yeah.
It brings me to the first topic that I
wanted to discuss with you, which is, um,
th this, all of these things
speak to a career of proactivity.
I'm looking back through the,
you know, through the years you,
you have always been at the,
the pointed end of the proactive stick.
And I find that interesting and the fact
that a lot of artists are very reactive
and event would take place and there's
a response to it or attribute to some
tragedy or, uh, some
sort of reaction based.
And I'm curious if you can speak about
what it's been like to always be in that
proactive space instead of
just a simple reactive space.
Wow. I dig it. I dig this, the whole,
the whole pointed end of the stick.
I mean, what's, yeah, Jeez. I mean,
I guess like anybody,
I've just been trying to speak
my truth, my experience, my,
my thoughts, my dreams,
my perception in my songs,
in my writing.
And um,
I guess personally,
I'm always compelled by art
that is takes risks, you know?
So, um, uh, I've always
kind of pushed myself.
I used to be really hard to
be that in the beginning.
You know,
I used to,
she's who's going to be at this show
tonight and on my mom or you know,
we'll high. Okay. And what will happen
when I say this or, you know what?
And a lot happens,
you know,
when you're like jabbing at stuff and,
um,
but I would say that the most important
thing that happened over the years was
that people came out and nowhere and
said, me too, or thank you, I'm a guy.
And all of that,
like hearing people repeatedly say,
I can't believe you just said that.
Thank you.
Just meant so much more than all the rest.
So it's kind of encouraged
me to just let it go.
Those ideas of what's private or personal
or inappropriate or this or that or
the other. It's like it's all
universal. It's none of it's unique.
It's curious that you said it used to be
more difficult for you because I would
almost think that now is a time period
of difficulty for anyone being proactive.
There's so much tension and so much
pushback to any push that is there.
Um,
does that weigh in at all when you're,
when you're about to step up and make a
bold statement of, like you said before,
it was the, you know, the idea
of all my moms in the audience,
I don't want to run a foul of
that, but now how, you know,
some fraction of the world,
the audience that are even more
dangerous than mothers. Yeah.
I mean
I feel like
the was really good to just come out of
the box with my mouth and spirit open
and just start.
I mean,
when I was a teenager and I
started making my own songs,
I,
I started pushing against that wall of
acceptibility and what you can and cannot
say and Ken and cannot be. And really
early on I just was like, you know,
f it just, just, what's going
to happen to me? Let's find out,
you know, and 25 whatever
it's been, you know,
30 years later,
I'm in a great position now.
People know, I mean, I weeded out the
riff raff a long time ago. You know,
people,
I think it's much more difficult
if you have a secret to let it go.
If you've never had secrets, it's easier.
It's better, you know, uh, you know,
people used to ask me about coming out
or this or then psych. I never was,
I was not in anywhere.
So,
and I think that that from
my experience it's better.
It's easier to do it that way to just,
I had a,
a young lady opening up my
shows recently who's had some
success with a,
a song online and she's a lovely,
lovely young gal and she's sort of
just embarking on a career in music.
And she was saying, Oh, you know,
I'm weird talking after one night.
And she said, I'm pro choice,
but I'm so afraid, you know, I Duh Duh,
Duh. I come from a traditional family,
I this and I that. And I said,
just say it, just say it.
The sooner you say it, the better.
Say who you are, what you believe,
what you think. Cause from
there it gets easier. Every day,
I'm going to change my plan now that
they brought this up because this,
this idea of just saying it.
Um,
I wanted to speak later
in the conversation about
the idea of directness and
metaphor. Um, but we sort of skipped
ahead to that in, in your music,
there's use of metaphor,
but where you really get masterful is
with just direct statements or like you
said, just taking it head
on and tackling it that way.
And I'm curious if you can talk about
the choices of when you want to say
something in a very direct fashion
or when you reach a little deeper for
metaphor to try and mask and idea
or, or, or Bo and ideas. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Right. Um,
I guess I use,
always had maybe just such a burning,
every time I see a eastern
medicine practitioner and they say,
Ooh, your spleen, whoa with
the spleen. I'm like, yeah,
I know you should see my 20 records,
spleen music.
And it's just, you know, it's just,
I have such an urgent need to,
I don't know,
beat back lies and silences,
um,
that often it drives me to just say it.
Um, I think that's just, you know,
where my music is coming from.
Sometimes I'm interested in how could
you say it without saying it or how could
you say, you know, um,
but oftentimes I've, I,
the direct route is what
is most appealing to me.
I used to get a lot of flack for
it. Like we were talking about, um,
a lot of resistance, a lot of pushback. I,
when you were forming your question,
I was remembering the first
time I went to Italy to play,
we were talking earlier about
touring in Europe and um, this was,
you know,
first time I went to Italy was probably
20 years ago and it was in an age of
flack, you know, that I was living in.
And I remember the first interview I
did an elite and the dude was like,
so many artists, you know,
they, they, they say,
they say it,
but they don't say it.
They say they laid in bed for
the hint that you just did.
And I was like, that's good. You're
saying that it's good. You know,
I'd never heard a positive
response to that before.
I just remember that.
So clearly that moment of maybe
somebody thinks that's good.
Well, it's curious with the things
that you've chosen to talk about,
and we spoke with a little bit
about this before as you said,
but I was immediately in
preparing for this conversation.
Just went through the entire
catalog again of flashing back.
Can I bless your heart live
to tell the tale, the fan.
A couple of things that caught with me
where this directness and uh, you know,
I mentioned before the
song like gratitude. Uh,
and recently of course me too has
found a life online and this sort of
understanding of, of women not being
alone in these situations and men as well.
In fact, um, but I
immediately went back to,
was it early nineties when gratitude
spoke exactly to that topic.
And you know, another example
would be like to the teeth.
This is something that is
decades old at this point,
but it's still modern day prescient.
Um,
when something happens in the world
that you have spoken or have tackled
directly on that flashes you back
10 years, 20 years into your career,
how does that land for you? How does,
how do you process something like me too,
in light of the fact that 20 years ago
you were standing up shouting exactly
these words.
Yeah. Sometimes it's a little
hard sickening. Um, you know,
to the teeth that you mentioned
is a song about gun violence.
A Song I wrote,
I dunno,
pushing 20 years ago when I thought
it was completely out of hand.
Um, so to pull that song
out now and play it is,
you know, kind of devastating. It's just,
and,
but things do change and often you think
he thinks this is just the way it is.
We just have to accept this is the way
it is. And then overnight it's not,
you know, and this me too moment
that we're in, you know, I think it,
it really speaks to how
much the dominant culture
yeah.
Is sees women now compared to
when I was writing that song,
even, you know, um,
the fact that we're hearing women give
voice to their experience as though it
matters, you know, um,
because they're becoming human in the
dominant culture and now we have to
accommodate that experience and those
people and those voices and those stories.
You know, it's one more
voice in the, in the chorus,
one more person with a seat at the
table, you know, and that's incredible.
I've seen a lot change, uh, in, you know,
I've seen the work of
feminism take hold around me.
Uh, you know, um,
from when I was first stomping
around saying stuff in my songs, uh,
I've never, and I've actually
on that tip, you know,
I've never felt a more receptive
world around me for a
lot of my feminist ideas,
you know,
so I actually am very hopeful right now.
You know, I know it's a
time of great peril. Uh,
and I mean to underplay that in a time
of great pain for a lot of people.
But I think that the possibilities,
I think there's a,
it's a transformative moment we're in,
especially around gender politics.
And there's, there's more of that on the
new album binary, which by the way, in,
in addition to this
incredibly proactive career,
it's also an incredibly prolific career.
And the fact that is,
I read somewhere that it's the 20th studio
album and I read somewhere else that
it was more than 20, uh, 20 albums.
Yeah, I know. What the hell.
That's amazing. It's at least 20.
There's 20 of those suckers. Um, yeah,
I don't know a lot of songs.
Kids change the game now.
I've slowed right down,
but, but, but not for lack of just
still creating amazing artwork.
There's the great,
great album here and more stuff.
Speaking to what we were talking about,
uh, immediately play, God jumps to mind.
Maybe you could talk about that song
and how, uh, the nexus and genesis.
Absolutely. Thanks. Um, yeah, I mean,
I started writing that song as kind
of a bragging, I was like, what if I,
what if I was like,
you know,
frost between Howlin Wolf and
missy Elliott, what would I,
right, right now, you know,
and I started, you know,
talking about my life as an emancipated
teenager, you know, I was on my own at 15,
and, um, you know, never
got nothing from nobody,
kind of,
you know,
and then the spleen took over and
something inside me just felt as I was
writing this bragging verse about how I'm
not a child and even when I was a child,
I didn't get a chance to
be a child. And I was, um,
not,
I was contributing in society.
I was a part of society really
early on. And then, you know,
my brain just sort of
flicked the that too.
And so you cannot treat me like a child,
you know,
you tell me what I can and cannot do
with my body when I should reproduce.
Uh, when I, uh, you know, if
I must reproduce or, you know,
this is
the kind of way that women still,
you know,
are treated in society is as though
they are inferior as though they are
children.
You know,
so I I think of reproductive freedom,
um,
as a civil right. You know, I think
that we need to talk about it that way,
address it that way.
I think we could use another
constitutional amendment
to guarantee women civil
rights.
Um,
yeah,
and I,
so the song just sort of mutated into a,
uh,
a women's civil rights anthem.
There's a lot of, um,
any, it speaks to the,
the title of the album binary.
There's a lot of dual meaning and I find
that interesting and that that story
started in one place and ended another,
um,
to talk about the concept of the entirety
of the album and being binary and what
that means,
where that's where that's coming from.
Yeah, sure. Here at Google, I mean,
binary to me, um, first of all is not,
I'm not really talking about either
or I'm talking about both always.
You know, I, um,
I had a run in with the
Internet a few years ago.
It came and found me in my house and
bit my head off and chewed on it for
awhile. And, um, uh,
that was sort of
the beginning of a lot of
meditations on consciousness for me.
Uh, oddly, you know,
these ones and Zeros came
and changed my life and hurt,
hurt me bad. And, um,
I,
I started to look at the whole world
is made of relationship basically that
every, anything that looks to be a
singularity is really a relationship.
Everything is two things spinning,
you know,
from our atomic structure, you
know, to the planets and the stars.
There is this fundamental design I
think that is made of relationship,
you know, and I'm kind of us, I'm
fascinated by quantum physics.
I don't understand it of course,
but I like to read about it and you know,
the quantum physicists I think through,
okay,
a long trajectory of masculine science
have come back around to sort of the
reality of the mother that
nothing exists on its own.
Only in relationship do
we, you know, I mean,
we are just, there's an infinite
field of possibilities until
something is observed and they will go
on to tell you that observing something
affects it,
that observing is interacting.
So with interaction comes existence,
you know,
I guess that's basically men
of course it's, you know,
it's not disconnected
with my feminism. And, um,
I think that that kind of the ways that
my brain has been spinning for the past
few years kind weaves through this record.
So that's why I took that song
title to title the whole record.
Well, and it goes even
further than that. Uh,
because this is a very interactive record
for you, I think in the creation. Right?
There's a lot of collaboration on this
record and it even on the technical side,
more collaboration than I
think you've done in the past.
How was the process of making binary a
different or familiar or unfamiliar or
taking a risk?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, often
I make records by myself.
I crawl into a hole depending on what's
happening in my life and make a little
record or a, you know, I, I
track the songs with my band,
but then I phots on my own
and finish it or something.
Solitary the record right before this,
I did a lot in the wee hours,
you know,
when the kids were sleeping
and headphones. And this time,
you know, my youngest is four, four
and a, you know, uh, uh, I just,
I needed to re enter the
world and interact with
adults and creative beings and
people who would bring ideas to
the table other than me. So I,
I tracked the tunes with not
just my core band rhythm section,
but a few other musicians,
uh, that I love.
Ivan Neville in New Orleans where I
live and Jenny Scheinman a beautiful
violinist from out west.
Um,
and then I just started calling up a lot
of other brilliant friends that I have.
I just don't,
didn't want to be alone.
I wanted community back in my life.
Um,
so there's a lot of beautiful players
and I had this kind of experience of like
the best Christmas ever again
and again, where, you know,
I sent Justin Vernon a track and then
my present comes in the mail being,
you know,
and I get to open it up and see this
beautiful chorus that he sang on my song,
or it's just the most wonderful presence
came back to me from my friends.
And, and then I even went one
step further than I've ever gone,
which is to have somebody else mix
the damn thing. I've always just do,
I can do this. Okay, that
sounds good. Right. You know,
Eh, you know, so my records,
so over the years are unique,
you know, and expressive,
you know, and suit. But,
you know, having brought, uh,
a creative mind like Chad Blake to
into this project to mix it remotely,
once again,
I just sent him raw tracks and I got
back mixes was breathtaking for me.
I was like, oh wow. What
if you're not crazy?
And you didn't just write the
songs? And so, you know, and,
and you came in with an objectivity and a,
and a skill that I could,
we'll never achieve and mixing
and perspective different
what, what a gift. Wow. You can really
do things in the mixing as it turns out,
you know, so, um, I don't
think I'll ever go back to,
I haven't been, you know, I mean I've
been thinking about it lately, you know,
the emancipated minor thing when
you're just, I got this, you know,
and you're just taking care of everything,
you know, now I'm 47 and I'm like, ah,
I don't have to do that anymore.
It took me a while to let go.
It is. It also, um, I found
that in listening to the record,
it's,
it's super broad in style and approach
and there's some stuff on here that is a
very classic Ani Difranco style.
Um,
there are other tracks on here
that are nearly hip hop songs. Um,
uh, and then, uh,
like spider is kind of this other end of
that spectrum and very indie rock kind
of way. Um, where did, where did the
diversity come from from this album?
Was it out of this collaboration or,
or where their trigger
moments that were like, Hey,
I'm going to go in this
direction for a reason.
Speak to that. Yeah. I mean,
I like, and I've been hearing
it from others that this,
yeah, the, the sort of diversity of
the sounds on this record and the,
and I think that has to do with
Chad and with, uh, you know,
the people that I worked with,
the musicians helping me translate my
songs and fully have helping me manifest
them fully.
I think that I've always
written really in a diverse way,
you know, um, I never kind of
want to write the same song twice.
So I'm always let me write a song,
standing on my head, you know, with the,
you know, a bucket on each foot
and see what that turns out like.
And so I've done that
all, but then, you know,
I think then I just play it like I
always do on whatever's sitting around.
And then I just sort of mix it
so you can hear everything. And,
but I think when other people come in
and enhance the creativity that exists in
the, you know, in the seed
of a song and they say,
well this sounds to me like we
should go over here and look,
I have a, I have an arc, we
can go over there, you know?
And so I think that these songs were
more fully realized in their differences
then then maybe on other records.
Well,
I'm happy to hear it because it does take
a lot of the music in a new place. Um,
and speaking of the new place,
you spoke of a little bit of the Internet
coming to bite you a few years ago.
I'm skipping past that.
I know that for binary,
there are some videos and we
were speaking about it before.
These were things that you had
sort of independently done.
I'm wondering if you could talk about
what it's like to be, as we said before,
sort of an old artists,
uh,
approaching that way and being thrust
into the situation to where maybe now just
an album's not enough.
Yeah, I, yeah, that seems to be true.
I think I've just a focusing or you know,
I'm a working musician and
playing live for people,
just being gathering with people.
I've,
I think the sort of fundamental,
uh,
reality of music as a social act is
really how I feel it and that's what
inspires me.
And so I think I'm most inspired on stage,
um, you know, spending an hour and a half,
two hours with people and the kind of
connections that you make and the kind of
less alone that we all feel when we
walk out of there. And the kind of,
that is what I live for.
Um,
and the rest of it,
I don't know,
it's all changed around me and I'd
be the last to really know, you know,
I think at one point in the
90s people were like, Ani,
how do you do it? You know,
show us how it's done.
And I'm so far from
being that guy anymore.
I'm an old lady and I have no idea how
you utilize the technology
and the media and
you know, to have a career
in music in the 21st century.
I just know that I like to play for
people live and if I can just do that and
pay my rent, tell I'm dead. I'll be okay.
When you were saying before that you
felt very flattered by your audiences
enjoying that moment with you in
participating in that moment with you.
I think it's very common for people to
go to shows and the first thing that
happens is the phone comes out.
Right?
Yeah. Right. We were talking
earlier this morning, um,
and I was telling Matthew,
I've have noticed this last couple
of months being on the road, um,
less, no phones, no
phones in the audience,
almost no phones, which is noticeable.
I feel like my audience where sort
of the last of the to bring to live,
you know,
the show through the phone and uh,
and when it came into this,
the space of my show is I just like,
ah,
I guess this is the world now.
This is,
there's nowhere to go that this
is not the world. So, all right.
And then these last
few months people just,
I got the feeling like people are,
haven't had enough.
They've had enough.
It's like I want an hour and a half of
being in a place and a time with the
people that I'm with.
And it just, it was like,
look at you guys.
There hasn't been one
glowing blue face tonight.
Congratulate fucking
lesions. We're all here. Maybe the um,
the escapism that the
phone initially served, uh,
is found again and putting the phone
away and, and actually being a part of,
yeah. Well we got deep. We got, did
you guys miss the whole conversation?
That meant anything cause we,
what's going on in new music and who
are the groundbreaking young artists of
today?
And I of course Peta will teach me
everything I need to know eventually about
that.
But we were wondering together if
this absorption into the Gizmos,
this endless distraction and
entertainment you know is has prevented a
generation or two of groundbreaking music.
You know,
you are not bored,
you are not desperate for connection so
you don't have to go into your garage
and invent some convoluted
way to connect users.
But,
but we were,
we concluded this morning or
at least we left off with,
well maybe,
maybe we're moving past the
end list days of absorption.
Maybe that in itself is becoming
boring for young people.
So maybe that next awesome band or
artist or what a is is right around the
corner now.
Hmm.
Well the, the speaking of next
is a good stepping off point.
So I will say that those of you
who have questions in the audience,
if you guys want to make
your way to a microphone, I
encourage you to do that. Oh,
spotlight right by the mic there.
Nice. Before we get into that,
I would like to talk a
little bit about next.
I know that next year has a lot of
interesting things. Cute up. Um,
specifically I think babe
fest is coming to New York.
Yeah, possibly. That's the
big idea babe fest in Central
Park. Oh, that would be no,
I hope. I hope. I hope.
Yeah. Anybody who has any
contacts with the summer stage,
people start pulling
your strings now a book,
but what else is coming up for for 2018
a book, a book, a book, what kind of book?
Complete sentences.
Spelling spelled all correctly.
Like I'm writing a book,
I'm trying to write a book and um,
are we,
are we talking to Ne Narrative?
We're talking memoir. Oh. But of
course it's all made up, right?
We all, you know, we're all
just making up the story,
but I'm, I'm, yeah,
I is an idea that I floated for years,
you know, uh, back when I was, you know,
the groundbreaking indie girl,
the concept was more like part manual,
part memoir.
This is what happened.
This is,
here's some tips on how course
that moment is past. Um,
and I'm just, I'm just
writing stories, uh,
in a different format. It's totally
different from songs and poems.
I,
it's crazy to me and it's all called
writing cause it's just feels so different
and it's processed. But I just, I dunno,
I just looking for challenges
I guess as a writer.
So that's what I'm up to.
Well,
when you finish you'll have to come back
and we'll do this all again and talk
about it. Okay, cool. Let's take a
question from the audience. Uh, hi.
I had a bunch of questions, but
when I saw you sing with Pr, uh,
I flashed back to 20 years ago in
my home tone seeing a delayed Craig,
Chris Whitley, perform with his
daughter Trixie on stage, uh,
probably around the same age as Peter.
And so I'm kind of curious if you
could talk a little bit more about the
dynamics of a family and music,
uh,
who's nudging who to perform together on
stage. How does that decision get made?
Um,
how would you draw a line balancing,
exposing her to the public on a stage two
photos versus I'm helping her find her
own voice and her art and their
craft for about your music future.
Yeah. Cool. Cool. Um,
well I guess first of all,
I start with Shi. I started with
her what she wants, you know,
she's been touring with me a lot,
you know, when she was a kid,
she was a road baby til three and a half.
And so she's pro at the touring business
and at some point more recently she
started saying,
mommy,
I want us to come sing on that
song or that. Okay. All right.
You know, don't push them
onstage, but say yes, if,
if that's what they choose
and it's, sorry, Peter,
that we're talking about. Yeah. Um,
but it made all the difference
for me as a working musician mom,
because
music was my first baby,
you know,
and the subsequent babies that have
arms and legs did day in and day,
not well for the guitar.
I mean,
they could be playing happily for if I
pick up the guitar and try to do my thing,
they shut me down, shut
me down. No drifting off,
mommy into your world.
Me. It's about me now.
And so that was hard as
an artist, you know, uh,
the little guy, I have a four year
old son and he's the same way now,
but as soon as peta decided
I want to be a part of that,
then it became our thing.
It was not my thing anymore.
And it changed everything. It changed
the whole atmosphere around music,
which is just thrilling to
me. I mean, I love to sing,
but I love to sing with my daughter
even more, you know? So yeah.
Now that we can make it
something we do together,
it's opened up a new whole new era for us.
Paper question stick one from the side.
Excellent. Hello. Hi. Hi. First off,
thank you so much for coming.
Um,
I truly believe you are one
of the greatest poets of
our time and don't actually
have a question. This is a statement I'm
going to embarrass myself. I apologize.
Um, I was one of those kids. I grew up
in rural Michigan. I was the g and LGBT.
I didn't have anyone to talk to and your
music got me through and I would not be
here today without you. So I just
wanted to say thank you. Thanks.
We had on but I get off
cause I'm probably gonna.
Yeah,
I'm going to cry with you.
Yes. Yay. Yay To realness and
being your whole authentic self.
Thank you for that moment
of vulnerability. Yeah,
I hear that a lot and it keeps,
it keeps me going
through the hard moments.
That means the world to me.
I got the question for me to you,
thank you as well,
but I want to kind of know about your,
how you feel about your brand
from an external standpoint.
I kind of see you have this personal
brand as I've been in this side of you all
of these years.
You now have a business brand,
you have this cultural brand as well.
And you also,
now I'm hearing you have this other thing
that's mommy hood that might prevent
either the evolution of, or the
building or separation of another brand.
What does your brand mean to you?
And can you share your
thoughts of that over time?
Yeah, sure. Um, let me see.
I think what I tend to do
is not think about it. Yeah.
Okay.
I, um, when,
when you were talking about the
elements in your question, um,
I was thinking about a story.
I hear so many wonderful stories from
people who have intersected my music or my
brand to even, um, I heard a story,
you know, and I get these
letters and, and uh,
the judge just like food for me, you
know, that, that nourish me back.
And, uh, I got a letter a little
while ago from a mom who, uh,
is a fan of my work and she had
a righteous babe sweatshirt,
you know, with the logo. Um,
and her young daughter said to her,
mommy, is that a girl or a boy? You know,
striking this muscle man pose,
but with a skirt, you know,
the little logo that started off
as a picture of me hamming it up,
you know, I hate cameras, so I'm
going to do something ridiculous.
And then that became the logo and
that became the brand, you know,
righteous babe.
And um,
so here's a little girl who I don't know,
talking to her mom who's found
something in my music. Mommy,
is that a girl or a boy? That's a
girl, sweetie. And then she took,
the little girl said is,
she's so, so, so, so strong.
And her mom said, yeah, she's
so, so, so, so strong. And she,
you know,
and this is all in the letter.
And then she said there was a
pause and her five year old said,
I want to be like that. And
I thought, Whoa, a logo.
Hmm.
I,
and I don't think that that's going to
inspire me to think about it or how can I
tweak the logo or how can we work
the brand to make more value for,
I just try to
do what I do and be who I am.
And write the best song I can be and
give it in the most honest way I can in
whatever moment and hope that
these peripheral things like,
you know,
the idea of righteous babe records and
the look of that logo and we'll do their
own work around that.
You know,
if I just stay focused on what I
know and what I'm good at, that,
you know, those, those peripheral
things like the righteous bay brand.
I mean we are trying to put
a festival together and,
and maybe I have been inspired by
my new team to contemplate it more,
um,
to try to reinvent righteous babe.
And what does it mean to
stand at the intersection of,
of art and politics and who else can
we help or invite in or what other
communities can we help,
uh,
to bring closer together to make
stronger through a festivals,
through a brand did festival,
you know,
so I try to work with people who
do understand such things and can,
you know, build momentum around them.
But for me, I just try to, you know,
focus on being an artist
and a mom.
Yeah.
A, it's curious, I'm going to
follow up on her question if I can,
cause the label came out of it as
a function of need, right? Uh, you,
you created it not to hate,
we're going to make a ton of
money by releasing albums,
but because you needed a
way to get your music out.
And I think what I have noticed is
even with other artists on the label,
it's not out of,
hey,
we're going to put this out and
make a ton of money off of it,
but it seems to come from
this music deserves it.
And I wonder if that
functionality speaks to,
to what you were saying as
far as not having to worry
about developing the brand,
just doing what needs to get done.
Yeah.
It's one of the great ironies
of my existence if you're me,
is this label entrepreneur that has
followed my name for 30 years and it's so
not the point.
It's like so far from the point that it's,
it used to really bug me, you know what
I mean? Of all the things that, you know,
songwriter, activists,
some, some entrepreneur,
you know. Okay. Right. I guess
I started a record company,
but the whole point was really to
avoid the music business. You know,
the whole point was can you just make
music your job without having to,
you know,
get in bed with business
people, prof, you know,
bottom line oriented people.
Not that the music industry is full
of bad people, they're good people.
Uh,
it just,
I think I was such an idealistic
kid that it's sort of, I looked at,
you know,
the intersection of sort of business
and corporate culture and an art.
And I see commodification,
I see everything beautiful and
vital come out of the underground,
get commodified and die, you
know? And I thought, yeah,
I don't want to be a part of that process,
even if it serves me, you know, I just,
I find that to be such a
bummer. Um, what, uh, what,
how else could it be done? You
know? So the point was really just
to never too, I mean for me to
just follow my teachers, you know,
the people that really made my world
bigger and less about myself instead of,
you know, you should wear this and play
this song and make this happen and do,
here's how to, you know, it's just
like, I don't want to think about that.
I want to think about something
meaningful. You know? So
yeah, I guess it was just like a,
it was a problem solving process.
It was never about running
a record company, but about
how can I dedicate it as,
as little energy in that
direction as possible.
Yeah.
We are running close to time,
so if you guys have a couple more
questions with taken please. Hello? Hello.
All right,
so that actually dovetails perfectly
with my question because I'm curious,
you said you set up the record label,
not out of the joy of wanting to run
and be a business owner, but just to,
you know,
improve your direct connection with the
audience and be able to get your music
to more people. And I'm curious if like
now speaking of the ones and Zeros,
do you feel like that's still working
or do you feel like you're sort of
inevitably in an embrace with Spotify,
Pandora, apple music, Google play music,
whoever, uh, and if you were a
young artist starting out right now,
would you try to leverage those or would
you still try and do the whole thing
yourself?
I mean,
there's so much to know and navigate now,
you know,
to have a career in music.
And I certainly don't think I'm a voice
of authority or knowing necessarily,
um, my basic approach is
to just let go, you know,
to just let go too,
you know,
as the music business and the world of,
changed around me,
like let go of the old and
there's music free now.
And can musicians have a job of music if
it's just free and you can't commodify
it at all, or how do you, and the
little guy is struggling so much and,
and you know, people have asked me what
I make about these streaming, you know,
and these, and for me, I think, uh,
you know,
I just have this sort of really basic,
you know, primal approach,
which is acceptance.
I can't control how
people get their music.
I,
I just let it all happen.
And I hope that the,
and I have found through this
just sort of ignorant but,
but faithful approach of I'm going to
apply as much consciousness as I can,
dig through my work and hope that that
comes back at me from the universe.
You know, hope that the universe
has a place for me in my art.
Um, it, it has found a place for
me. So I'm one of the lucky ones.
I mean, maybe it's easy for me to
speak in such trite terms because the,
the universe has held me
and I'm, I'm very lucky. Um,
but I think that when
you are in the groove,
when you're in the flow of yourself,
you know,
whoever you are and
whatever you have to offer,
there is a place in the universe for it,
you know,
so to calculate,
what obstacles, you know,
change the flow or guided or,
or, you know, I don't worry about that.
I just worry am I being true to myself?
Am I giving what I have to give?
Am I listening to,
you know,
the voices that guide me.
Um,
and uh, so far it's, it's worked out.
Yeah. I don't know if that's ever
the answer, but thank you. Thank you.
Well,
and I want to thank you.
I want to thank you for your time
to come here and be with us today.
I want to thank you for your
thoughtfulness in this conversation.
It's really been a pleasure
and I hope that everyone else would
join me in thanking you as well.
We are running close to time,
but I'm wondering if you would do us,
your honor, would you mind performing
another song? Yeah, we'll play one more.
Excellent. All right. Thank you so much.
Let me see if I
where's Peter? You were saying, oh we go
so yeah.
So this is that song play God
that we were talking about
intergenerational feminism.
I was done 16 showing up.
Fuck I was out there in the ring
learning how to kick some Ma.
I was done 16 using my mom Musky.
It was all on me.
Yeah it was all on me.
One no free ride.
Why are no you I pull my way.
Yeah I paid Matt do this and I showed
up to and list on the first day of crew
have there you have that you
ski every chance.
Sack kn and I pay my taxes.
Lack any working man and I feel
my right to choose.
You don't get to play God man.
You don't get to play man.
Angie,
you're special.
You get much ma much smaller
government religion Patri high g
Thang Debbie.
He he oh oh yes.
One day.
Oh one day he
leave this one time
cause they have is one thing that
a man needs to be truly free.
This is the modern world and
have one thing is mum needs
to
control her body. He,
yes,
I pay that price on top of the front
saying each mom bill each month of rec.
Good name.
NHC that die,
cry,
bleed.
So you can tell me no,
you can't tell me.
You can tell me you can't tell me.
Ah
Yes,
my blood that so I had my life.
So that is tree can grow.
You don't know [inaudible] like I had no.
So you came tell me you can't tell me.
You can't tell me.
No,
you can't tell me you get to
run a borough and your special,
you get much,
much
sawdust.
Patriarchy.
This Julie, this what day? Debbie?
E. E. Oh yes. One Dang.
E d. E. Oh
one thing me, he ah, ah,
leave this one.
Cause I'm my bra the Ski Zach
Kane and I pay my taxes man.
And I feel
my right to Jew saying you
don't get to play God man.
You don't get to play God man.
You don't fit man.
A dude,
Franco, Peter de Franco.
Thank you both very much.